you begin this half-hour with ovens
working overtime social distancing is
led to a baking boom even with those now
earning their bread and butter from home
and that creativity in the kitchen is
baking goods flying off the shelves ed
O'Keefe has more on how companies are
trying to keep up with demand all over
the world and all over social media
people under lockdown are whipping up
cakes cookies and lows of sourdough
America's interest in baking is on the
rise I've found myself I asked for this
reason is that I have some I have this
stuff right here in the past month
Americans about more than twice as much
flour as they did last year and yeast
sales are up 182 percent it's leaving
supermarket shelves bare empty shelves
of fire it's a supply chain problem says
King Arthur Flour co-ceo Karen Kohlberg
there is no shortage of wheat in this
country we have a lot of wheat and we
are in the process of working with our
partners or milling partners to get that
wheat milled and bagged if you're
struggling to find flour in yeast you
might check a local bakery like bread
first in Washington Mark first in
Burke's James Beard Award winning shop
is known for its baguettes
well now it's also become a bit of a
flower shop I never imagined that we
would be changed so profoundly as we
have been changed by any event like this
after DC's stay at home orders began
sales manager Scott Outlander started
getting frantic calls as people were
running out of flour they'd cook do you
have flour yeah we've got flour I'll
give you a bag so we'd run into the
bread bakery and bag up flour I'm buying
as much flour to sell to customers raw
as our bakers are buying to ship out his
finished product
bakeries have their own supply chains
and though it's usually too much for the
average home baker I've got older women
who are throwing sacks of flour over
their shoulder and taking it out 25
pound bags I've had a guy this morning
about a 50-pound bag of fly
what do you do with 50 pounds I have no
idea what they do with 50 pounds of
flour Paige woody found a use for a 50
pound bag when her freelance worked
right up last month she turned to sour
dough her hobby became a way to help
others she calls it dough good two
essential workers and it's just a bit
amazing because it really has connected
everyone Baker's say bread can be more
than just a meal you're constantly all
day long in the fermentation process why
is begging the national pastime
baking is it's something everyone can do
it's thing that's comforting I think
it's a really nice distraction bread is
what sustained civilizations so it's
deeply in our soul that bread is
important so it makes sense that in a
time when people need comfort they turn
to bread for CBS this morning Saturday
at O'Keeffe Washington
I'll sorry but baking is so precise I
don't even attempt it but we do have a
resident Baker at CBS this morning and
check out her I G from curious yes she
can bake yeah Karen Cleveland delicious
yes I agree and Michelle you know I love
to bake but I actually I'm a cookie a
cake all of that I've never even tried
bread maybe this is my time I don't know
neither it is so tough he got you should
check here his social accounts she has
she has some some great stuff and also
some solid mask selections in there in
ads piece so what well done all the way
around